[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm rhett and i'm link this week at the
round table of dim lighting
we're talking about the enneagram and
we're talking about
specifically my number and your number
and if you don't know what the crap
we're talking about well we'll give you
a little bit of primer
on that to start out yeah i mean okay
you know i'm mr disclaimer so i'm going
to give you a few disclaimers before we
get started
first of all don't forget the first
disclaimer is the third episode of
ronstadt is out
and this is where you get to meet uh one
of link's characters uh
maybe i mean i think my favorite
character that you play is gus
twitty but this is oh really this is a
this is my favorite it's a very
good character as well yeah you get to
meet knee slapper episode three of
ronstat so
wherever we get your podcast it's
scripted you can catch up
at any time get on the train a few
disclaimers
uh the first disclaimer is
for anybody who knows anything about the
enneagram you already know
that everyone did their enneagram
podcast like four years ago
minimum and so we're late to the game
and
these disclaimers are actually coming
through my wife who is
the the most knowledgeable person i know
about the enneagram
so just let you know this is from los
angeles jessie lane interiors
oh gosh i don't um but we're not that's
not the podcast we're doing anyway this
is the
the bigger disclaimer is what she wanted
me to do she said don't tell me you're
doing an episode on the enneagram she
said are you going to do what everybody
does
and you're going to not bring on an
expert to talk about the enneagram
you're going to talk out of your ass
about the enneagram and you're going to
misinform and mis-educate i said no no
no
that is not what we're doing because we
are not trying to educate you about the
enneagram
we are talking about our experience
with the enneagram but just in case
you're the kind of person who wants to
be
oriented to what the enneagram is if
you're not already
in order to then enjoy or appreciate the
discussion that we're going to have
i do encourage you to go to other
sources to figure out what the enneagram
is because we're going to give a very
brief explanation but this is
not comprehensive and it's not meant to
be authoritative in any way okay
man you're really hedging it's not you
almost sound like
a one like a perfectionist who's like if
i if i'm going to be criticized for this
well myself i don't want to do it a
self-press 3
is the closest to a 1 of any spot on the
enneagram
uh now but the other thing i'll say uh
along that lines is
there's a bunch of great sources i'm a
little bit biased towards the enneagram
institute just because
it's a website not a book so it's really
easy to go to and it's free
and you can go over there and you can
get a brief description of the different
personality types and you can get a
brief description of what the enneagram
is in general
uh and there's a lot of information for
free you can also take the test which i
do think you have to pay for
on the enneagram institute anyway um but
the thing that we really want to talk
about is just kind of explore
our experience in in being exposed to
the enneagram
and starting to understand what our
numbers are and how that has impacted
how we how we think about ourselves how
we think about each other
and the people and other people that we
interact with
like our wives um we're thinking we're
gonna make this a two-parter because
today we're going to talk about
uh both of our numbers and our
experience with that right
and the insights we've gained into what
makes
ourselves tick and then probably next
time we'll spend more time talking about
how different numbers relate to each
other how the fact that i'm a three in
links of one like what that means
in our relationship the way our
marriages function
with the insights that we've been given
by learning about the enneagram
but let's just start just really quickly
just saying a couple things about what
it is okay so
you hear the word enneagram it sounds a
little bit like pentagram
it kind of looks like a pentagram well
it sounds like kilograms because
it is a nine pointed diagram
that essentially represents the fact
that there are or the idea i don't know
i don't want to use the term fact
because this is not scientific this is
very
observational a nine pointed symbol
this sounds creepy man this the idea is
that there are nine personality types
now
just this is not astrology
if you're into astrology good for you i
don't believe in it but astrology is
based on the idea
that depending on at what time you were
born during the year there are certain
things that are true about your
personality
the enneagram has nothing to do with
that sort of idea that there's some sort
of cosmic thing determined about you
based on when you were born i think of
it more like the myers-briggs
personality test but that kind of sells
it short
in terms of the history of it and uh i
mean wouldn't you say
yeah well i'm gonna i'm gonna just read
to you something from
my favorite website the neogram
institute.com okay
from one point of view the enneagram can
be seen as a set of nine distinct
personality types
each number on the enneagram denoting
one type
it's common to find a little of yourself
and all nine of the types although one
of them should stand out as being
closest to yourself this is your basic
personality type everybody emerges from
childhood with one of the nine types
dominating their personality
with inborn temperament and other
prenatal factors
being the main determinants of our type
in other words
this is mostly to do with discovering
who you are just
genetically uh this isn't necessary i
mean
you can argue about how much is nature
and how much is nurture but this is just
based on observation it seems like there
are nine sort of dominant
types of personalities that people can
uh exhibit
and for me and i i think that i can i'm
speaking for link as well i mean
the main like okay so what's the point
why what what do you do
why why are you into this and why has
this been impactful
or impactful um i mean you just said the
same word twice
for me but i emphasized a different
syllable the main benefit
uh is the realization that i
am not my personality that's actually a
huge part of this for me because we tend
to
get confused and tend to think that we
are
the way we act and the way we think
right uh
and but my personality and your
personality
is a protective shell that we have
constructed to protect our inner self
right
this is something i explored in therapy
and the way the enneagram kind of lined
up with it was pretty awesome
but and the more that i understand my
personality the
more that i understand what the shell is
and how the shell was constructed
the more transparent it becomes and the
more i can look through it
and see my true inner self and that's
good for me
personally but it's also good for my
relationships because i'm able to
experience my true self express my true
self but also
let you as someone in my relationship
with me experience my true self
my experience is that it's a nice
companion
knowledge base to therapy
now i don't actually talk about the
enneagram in therapy sometimes i might
refer to it but i
access some of the things that i'm
learning in those conversations
in therapy and so it it can definitely
be very insightful or i'll also say
heavy you know it can really help you
get access
into you know what's going on inside
and then help you understand why you're
doing
the things that you do and respond to
certain situations
um and that that's a very rewarding
process but it can also
be um you know it's work
it can and it it sometimes you know you
can be
it could be painful you know to get into
it but i'll say
also as i was exposed to it through
our group of friends that were into it
years ago it was also
fun because it just i
felt like all of a sudden some things
kind of clicked into place
and i understood things and i could
you know all of all the quirks that i
have and i got plenty
i didn't feel as alone or as weird i
still love to celebrate my weirdness
and my uniqueness but
um there was a bit of validation that
like
oh i'm not alone i can as much as i want
want to i can apply the labels
associated with one
and and feel not so
not not so alone um but and it's kind of
it i mean if you're into it it's fine
and you
you know if you're not into it and you
have friends who are into it it can be a
little pretentious and annoying
i also as well but i'm into it so i'm
probably just pretentious and annoying
but
and it provided a common language for
our friend group to
understand each other much more quickly
on a deeper level
and to this day we still refer to those
things
but i mean there was a big wave when we
were all reading the books and
talking about it that now it just kind
of comes up occasionally
um so you know i'll say it can be it can
be painful
it can be heavy but it can also be fun
and i think we're gonna
talk about both those things today and
when you when you learn
more about your personality and you and
you kind of learn through this this
you know the filter of the enneagram
uh it's interesting because you're kind
of learning
what your strengths and weaknesses are
at the same time because
the old adage your greatest strength is
usually your greatest weakness
and what makes you a one what makes me a
three what makes you whatever you
are there are some strengths and
weaknesses that come along with that and
usually again the thing that makes you
um an asset in a relationship
or an asset on a team also
in when it's not healthy can make you a
liability and and i think that that's
that's the biggest thing that we've been
able to learn because
as you as you kind of understand like
when i'm like okay
that's why i'm oh i'm do i do this thing
and now that i can actually read about
it and i can see like you were saying
that oh there's a whole lot of other
people who
have this same struggle or have this
same tendency it's
it suddenly kind of neuters it a little
bit you know what i'm saying it takes
the power
out of it and i know and i don't feel as
controlled and actually feel like
there's a little bit of hope
for dealing with this particular thing
that right when you separate yourself
from your personality yeah then and
that you've constructed then you can
start to change your habits and your
actions
and your you can dismantle your uh
unhealthy defense mechanisms
and you know i'm not great at it and
i've kind of gone away from the
enneagram i haven't been reading
a lot about it in a few years but it was
nice to
kind of get a refresher on it let's go
quickly through all of the types okay
but i mean because we're just going to
talk about
my type in your type today but i'm sure
people want to hear
and you know there's there's quizzes and
you can go to the you can go to the
website and you can
start to read these books and and type
yourself
and it's going to take a little bit more
work than just the the one
liner that i'm going to read right now
but i'll i'll just go and
um numeric order not because that puts
me first
just because i mean i am a one type one
is called the reformer
some people might call it the
perfectionist uh one book that we'll
refer to
calls the one the machine
which i kind of like that the rational
idealistic type
principled purposeful self-controlled
and
perfectionistic type
two you got the helper
that's the caring interpersonal type
demonstrative generous people pleasing
and possessive jessie
this is my wife which we can talk about
next week
type three you've got the achiever that
is you rhett this is me
do you do you like any of the other um
names besides the achiever uh well the
same book
the millenniogram which we will
recommend later
calls this the winner i like that
the success oriented pragmatic type
adaptive excelling driven and
image conscious type four
you've got the individualist the
sensitive
withdrawn type expressive dramatic
self-absorbed and temperamental
type 5 the investigator the intense
cerebral type perceptive innovative
secretive and isolated
type 6 the loyalist this is my wonderful
wife christy
the committed security oriented type
engaging responsible anxious
and suspicious
type 7 the enthusiast
the busy fun-loving type spontaneous
versatile distractible and scattered
type 8 the challenger the powerful
dominating type self-confident decisive
willful and confrontational
type nine wrapping things up you've got
the peacemaker the easygoing
self-effacing type
receptive reassuring agreeable
and complacent now
there's a couple of ways to figure out
what you are
uh and the in the one way is the test
what i will say about the test is like
the the
it's actually called the ready r-h-e-t-i
it's an acronym for something uh from
the enneagram institute
has been evaluated to be like 72 percent
accurate so in other words
i don't think i ever took it so i took
that one and there's some other other
free ones that you can take
online and you're you might not always
score i usually um like 90
of the time three will be the thing that
hits the pings the highest right
um but another way to sort of figure out
what you are
in addition to the test is to read in
depth about each one
and see which one resonates the most
with you and i would go as far i think
the way that my wife
put it is the one where it feels like
they're reading your mail
you know what i'm saying because you're
like starting to get a little
embarrassed you're gonna have a little
bit of shame and embarrassment
uh some self-consciousness that is
associated with the
negative qualities of each type and if
and it's really those
negative qualities that you you begin to
feel that oh
that's me oh you got me yep you call me
out and when i read about
three it's clear as
day that that's what i and i think you
feel very strongly
in the same way about the one now some
people might not it might be like i
and again this isn't it's not science
this is a
observational thing that just kind of
helps you think about yourself so
don't feel too discouraged if you're
like i can't really figure this out
in an afternoon uh maybe it's obvious
for you maybe it's not but just
be patient with it if this is something
that you want to pursue so let's dig
into our numbers but first
let's promote some merch i got this mug
sitting here
you want to travel you want to stay
hydrated then
you need the mythical mug that thing
this thing is sharp
what no it's not sharp it's very safe
you just
i mean if if you're a type six you're
like i'm not gonna
get a sharp travel mug uh
no it's like it it pops open in a way
that
it get it's it's perfectly designed so
that
you can drink it and then seal it up
without having to touch
any of the stuff that you don't want to
touch with your mouth
because i'm a one i endorse this mug and
also endorse the wacky design
of the good mythical morning mug as
wacky
mythical.com get yourself some mug
action
okay um i mean since one comes before
three
just go ahead and uh all right i'll kick
it off but we'll bounce back and forth
yeah yeah
yeah um i it definitely was
obvious that i was a one in my mind very
quickly i mean
even without knowing about the enneagram
my perfectionistic
tendencies you know if
maybe it's because i'm a one or
that i identified with it immediately um
or maybe it's just like the concept of
being a perfectionist
is something that people talk about more
often than some of these other types
maybe i don't know i i can't tell
because i'm kind of on the inside of it
but but people tend to think they can
spot a perfectionist because
you know it it's it's a familiar term
right
so i kind of always consider myself a
perfectionist very meticulous
um so as i started to re read about it i
was like oh yeah i didn't play with my
toys
i posed my toys in the way that i wanted
them and i never touched them again
right you know i look over
my family's shoulder when they're
loading the dishwasher and i just can't
help
but re reload it once they're done
basically with any type of procedure
i always think i know the best way to do
it
and i just can't help myself to get my
hands in there
and to rearrange it gotta make things
right
right that's i mean that's a big part of
it it goes a lot deeper than that but
i mean speaking of going deeper i guess
we can talk about the childhood message
of it all
sure yeah is there so in
the complete enneagram it's more of the
reference book that
that we've both read well i think that's
27 past to greater self-knowledge that's
the one that i read i didn't read the
other one well
the the the unconscious childhood
message that the one that i just told
you about i know is in the wisdom of the
enneagram because that's what i was it
could
also be in the complete initiative yeah
it it says
chaos or uncertainty or anxiety in the
family motivates the one
child to take on the task of providing
order and structure for
himself the coping strategy of adhering
strongly to sound rules
and routines and standards of behavior
provides the one with inner cohesion
and security as well as protection from
criticism
so you know it's it's not that
my my mom didn't have a lot of rules
actually
um i things were things were pretty
loose but i definitely had this sense
that i needed to be a good child and
that i needed to
follow the follow the rules even and i
would make them up for myself
so i can definitely see i mean
some people will assert that you're
you're kind of born with a number
and that it just kind of manifests
itself through
the message that you receive as a child
and it's it's like the first litmus test
of
kind of what your number is other people
may say different things but
for me i think there was there was this
perceived
insecurity and that some of it was
it was up to me to to make sure that we
were good
you know it was like it was it was
it was me and my mom you know i remember
things like it just being
okay my mom's getting a divorce now it's
just me and my mom
in like late grade school
and just kind of internalizing the fact
that
i need to do my part to walk the line
i don't you know i don't want to cause
any trouble i don't want to be the one
to
to to create any sort of split here
i don't nothing was to the point where
like i mean i'm certainly
continuing to explore those things from
my childhood
in therapy and in in my own work but um
i wouldn't say that it was
it was traumatic to the point i mean i
just think that that's how i responded
to it
right with i can order my zone i can
stay in
in my my room can be my place and
if there's if anybody has expectations
of me
i need to do everything i can to follow
those
so it it does resonate in that way
it i think the the childhood message uh
is
it's not okay to make mistakes right and
again i think that was not anything that
was i didn't have a drill sergeant
of family members that were saying you
know and i never experienced a lot of
punishment
it was all something that i put on
myself and that i definitely
believed but as a defense mechanism of
things going wrong
it if anything goes wrong it can't be
because
i didn't do something right if i knew it
if i'm culpable
and and just to give people an idea of
how
personal how much you take it upon
yourself
it's not just the the feeling that you
can't make mistakes
i mean like the basic fear of a one
according to the enneagram institute is
of being evil or defective
you know what i'm saying so it's not
about like if i make a mistake
it's going to screw things up it's it's
about you and
the core of my being if i do something
wrong i'm bad i am a
yeah it's not just i did something wrong
i am wrong and
you know in the in the evangelical
environment that
we grew up in it you know that is a
tenet of the faith is that
you you're born into sin so you're
you're born
guilty and in in need of
punishment in you deserve punishment you
know
just just by virtue of being born and
existing
and i i never questioned that it just
it i accepted that uh
in maybe it resonated with me and
uh i internalized that right and so that
was that was a defining
belief in a defining part of my
experience as well well it's it's all
you know the different environments that
you find yourself in
will might exacerbate it right and i
think
interestingly i mean one of the things
we didn't say at the top
is there is a definitely a spiritual
aspect to the roots of the enneagram and
so it actually
the enneagram is talked about quite a
bit in christian circles right
both both the evangelical circles but
also sort of post-christian
or liberal christian progressive
christian circles um
you don't have to have any sort of
spiritual identity or
you know that doesn't have to be a part
of your background in order to
appreciate like links talking about the
practical
side of things but when you're in that
environment where
you're being told that you're bad and
that is
your ultimate problem i think that that
probably
speaks to a lot of the ways that we
processed our whole spiritual
experience so differently you know what
i'm saying which will get into what
how a three navigates the spiritual
space you talk about me in a second
yeah for me it was okay my
everything that i learned in church
growing up was okay
a set of rules and a set of beliefs
in an entire world view that's
completely organized
that i was like okay it gave me a sense
of comfort that
that existed all i had to do
was live up to it and you know
follow through with the actions oh yeah
and it
and that's not you know that's not
ultimately the point of it
but that was certainly what i fixated on
right you know was it wasn't a
connection in a relationship with god
and if you
if you if you replay my my spiritual
deconstruction episodes
through this lens of being a one it it
definitely makes sense and
uh it's it's helped me process it
another part of it is
like i said protection from
criticism like trying to do everything
you can so that someone else can't point
out
your your fault you know i i think about
when i was dating christy
and um i was just i was reading all
these books i wanted to do it right
you know i my dad i i never lived with
my dad
you know he left when i was two and then
you know my mom got remarried there was
a
and then there was a divorce i don't
think i ever blamed myself
for for either one of those things but
how i internalized it is is a different
question
and it i can definitely see
when i was dating christy i was like i
don't i want to make sure i do it right
i want to i want to read all the books
so that no stone is left unturned
with what with this decision i'm gonna
make should i ask her
to marry me and i remember i remember
the summer where you're trying to figure
this out
and you were like asking so all these
questions and you were like
weighing all these things you were
meeting with other people there was like
pro
con list that i would make and it was as
if someone was looking over my shoulder
um analyzing my choice so that so that
if they
said why are you doing this i would have
all the reasons yeah
and and not having any i mean we weren't
very in touch with
who we were at all in college but
you know i just interpreted it as links
being weird about this decision it was
just simple as that because i
specifically remember just telling you
i was just like do you want to marry her
right if the answer is yes then just ask
her to marry you it was
for me it was it i yeah and i tried to
simplify it to that
level and then you were like no no no no
it's not that's it's
how could you just make a decision based
on what you want
my mom always tells the story of when i
you know we went out to dinner and i was
like mom i looked at her and i was like
mom
i think i love her and she was like you
think
it's you know it's of of course you do
you know it's like finally you're
figuring this out and poor christy it's
like she had to wait for me to like
justify the fact that i loved her to
to to some and it wasn't to god it was
to like any outside criticism so that
you know again i just didn't want to
make any mistakes
and as a one you don't you don't want to
you know having to defend having to say
yeah
i you know i didn't do this right i
didn't look i didn't i didn't look at
all the information
i didn't do everything i could have it
was
you know it was i was kind of trapped
and i robbed myself
of a lot of the experience of
experiencing
falling in love with christy and being
in love
and i would apologetically explain
love as something that wasn't a concrete
reason
you know so you were trying to break it
down due to something that was even more
pragmatic than it than it can be
i mean for what's the childhood message
for the three or where or well start
wherever you want to
i don't have a i don't have the perfect
episode in my mind that i want you to
i don't want to hear you're really
resisting you're really resisting
so
here's one way that i knew i was a three
the day that jessie told me about the
enneagram and she said there are
nine personality numbers
and i was like which one's the best one
[Laughter]
i was joking but honestly
that's how a three approaches every
single
situation is how can i
be the best in this environment
in this with this challenge right so
again
little description of the threes again
the achiever the performer the winner
threes are self-assured
attractive now the reason that it says
attractive is not because
you're naturally good looking it's that
you're image conscious so no matter
how ugly you actually are even if you
don't have a chin
right you can grow a beard over that
chin and be like
that guy is not bad looking don't shave
you see what i'm saying that's what a
three can do charming
ambitious competent energetic they can
also be status
conscious and highly driven for
advancement they're diplomatic and
poised
but can also be overly concerned with
their image and what others think of
them
they typically have problems with
workaholism and competitiveness who's
that
what at their best self-accepting
authentic
everything they seem to be role models
who inspire others
so the childhood message
uh and this is this is interesting right
so on the surface it's something that i
think many of you can relate to
and that is most
parents and i'm one of them make the
mistake
of sort of giving praise
and rewards and love to your children
when they do things well
they make good grades they perform well
in sports
and some kids kids who are threes
internalize that message
to this hyper drive level where they
actually begin to attach their own
self-worth
to having pleased their parents so this
doesn't mean that my parents did
something wrong
and telling me that it was good to make
good grades or that being good at
basketball was something they were into
it's that the three
takes that and builds an identity that
is based on
what someone else wants
so they call the three the chameleon in
a lot of way
it because what they can do is
you put us into a situation put us on a
basketball team
we're gonna figure out how to be the
best player on the basketball team put
us into a classroom we're gonna figure
out how to
be the smartest person in the classroom
if we can't be the smartest we're going
to be
the best person who's giving a speech
we're going to find
something that we can do and if we can't
do it if we start thinking well i
actually can't cut it here we bail and
we go to
all the other things that we can do and
we learn how to navigate and be good
at it i see this rep pattern repeated
so many times in my life academically
with sports with our
career you know uh
they're the ultimate fake it to till you
make it right
threes will go into a situation knowing
that they do not know how to execute or
be good at something
but with this belief i'll figure it out
i'll get into the situation i will adapt
i will learn
and i will come out on top and there's
just this pathological belief
that that's how you can approach
everything now [ __ ] artist
the interest well we can be very
deceptive and we can be a lot of
politicians
a lot of politicians are threes um bill
clinton
probably i i got a list here yeah but
but michael jordan now see a politician
i mean a lot of people who have
succeeded in a
like tiger woods is a three a lot of
people who have succeeded
sort of exceptionally in a particular
field to a maniacal level happen to be
threes
oprah but oprah but what are we running
from
why uh why are we like this why am i
like this
so you know
i think this is the thing that has been
so
impactful and trans the beginning of
transformative as it comes to like my
therapy and exploring these ideas
is that actually our basic
fear is of being worthless the
unconscious
childhood message that we received was
not that we received but that we latched
on to again i want to make sure that
this isn't coming across it's like
blaming your parents did something
this is what we latched on to because of
our disposition
the message that i received and believed
was it's not okay to have your own
feelings and identity
now there's a lot of reasons why that
might be the case
but what you end up doing is you
to not have your own identity what what
that means is that
threes have a have a really difficult
time
figuring out what they want because what
they're really good at is figuring out
what you want
what the environment that they they want
you know
think about campus ministry right i have
had a tendency throughout my entire life
when you put me into an environment i
find a way to navigate to the top of it
right so what did i do in campus
ministry we went to
we went to one campus crusade event
and i saw that there was a guy up there
talking
every week he was introducing people he
was making jokes he was in videos
and it just clicked and it wasn't a
conscious process it was like i'm going
to be that person
i because i can't navigate a space
in any other way and so the next year
i was that person right and so
but what are we what are we running from
we believe that the moment that we stop
asserting ourselves and the moment that
we stop being
this thing that other people have found
value in that we don't have any value
that we are worthless so it's actually
this tricky thing where it's not this
thing
we don't actually think that we're great
we actually think that we're not great
we think that we are ultimately
worthless unless we can do something for
you
unless we can perform in a way that
you're like
good job great job and if we don't get
that we begin to
disappear i mean the worst fear that i
have is like
being incapacitated like literally like
what if i'm in an accident and i can't
do what i do anymore
like that is what a three is scared of
because the moment that
people have to and this is we also tend
to be incredibly independent
i don't want you doing something for me
don't help me with something because
that means that i'm that
i can't do it and i'm and and i might be
worthless
so receiving things from people
receiving help from people
we're not good at that because we want
to
do it again not because we think it
comes across as arrogance
i'm very aware of that it comes across
like oh you're arrogant you're prideful
you think you're the [ __ ] that's sort of
the external
impression that we can give the soft
uh underbelly of that is we actually are
are
afraid that we're not those things we're
afraid that we're worthless we're afraid
that if we cannot
perform for you then we will fade away
into non-existence
that's yeah and that's that's kind of
sad but it's nice to get in touch with
that so you can start to say okay how am
i going to grow how am i going to
integrate
these insights because for me it's yeah
it's
if i'm not you know i i guess i'm
afraid of there not being an answer or
they're not being
a like a perfect way
you know it's like if there's if there's
not an answer
how am i what am i supposed to do but
again one step below that
if my ultimate fears of being worthless
your ultimate fear is of being bad yeah
of being yeah corrupted of being
fundamentally flawed
as opposed to being fundamentally
good nailing it nailing it and you know
what
uh we'll get into this in a second
there's there's subtypes right and so
there's wings and there's subtypes we'll
talk about that
but the specific subtypes that we are
actually makes us
similar in some really interesting ways
we'll talk about that but the the
the thing about like this desire to be
um to not make a mistake to be good
that the one has and then this desire to
accomplish and i'm not saying that
there have been some situations and i
can't i wish i could think of one
where we have to make a decision about
something
and it's a much easier decision for me
because i'm just like
do we want to do this or would this be a
good
look and then you'll kind of get caught
up on
yeah but is this the right thing to do
yeah you know and i i actually think
it's a really good balance
because it the the sort of the one-two
punch of that decision-making process is
it can be very powerful uh but there are
a few times where i'm just like oh link
is really
link is really spending a lot of time
thinking about
the merit of the like the moral merit of
this and i'm spending a lot of time
thinking about like
what it will do for us i'm not talking
about like oh i'm gonna bend the rule
now threes will do that threes will
bend the rules three threes we'll break
the law threes will
lie in order to take advantage of you a
healthy three
doesn't do that i consider myself a
three that is moving towards health and
as at times healthy
so that being deceptive is not a i'm not
a liar
you know that's that's not a that's not
a problem
um i'm not gonna lie to you to try to
get something past you
i guess there may have been times in my
life that i would have done that but
thankfully that hasn't been one of the
things that i've had to deal with
one of the things i guess to bounce back
to the one
like a one of the hallmarks of
oneness is the an incessant
inner critic now a lot of people
and i guess of of many different numbers
can describe having an inner critic an
inner voice that is
analyzing and and assessing
your performance your actions whatever
the case may be
measuring you against the standard but
the inner critic of a one
is a constant thing
um again to quote the textbook
ones internalize a parental voice that
functions
therefore as an internal critic or coach
this coping strategy of proactively
criticizing oneself
and trying to do things correctly prior
to coming under parental scrutiny
uh can avoid outside criticism and
punishment
and it's it's it's it can be crushing
because it's so
constant like i remember when i had my
lawn mowing job
um when i was like 14 15
and on into 17 you know around
my nan and papa's house like they got me
this gig
and first of all nana was the one who
was like i remember she would all say
don't half-ass it
if you're gonna do anything go all the
way do it right i mean she was she was
the closest to like
the like the concrete voice of
find the right way to do it and do it
right or don't do it at all
um chew your food 30 times
right you know chew your food a lot it
was probably and she might have never
said 30 times she might have just might
have just thrown that out there as like
a ballpark
figure which is really high but to me
that was like okay
now i know i'm going to count 30 times
every time and when i'm done with this
podcast i'm going to go
to the dentist and get fitted for a
mouth guard
so that you know i don't chew chew my
mouth to shreds you're chewing while i'm
sleeping you're you're practicing
chewing while you're sleeping
as a 43 year old but i remember i would
cut
grass and i usually didn't have my
cassette walkman
because i didn't want to get it dusty
and i would
and definitely not a cd player because
it would skip too much
so i would just be there along with my
thoughts
and my thoughts were my inner critic
in the form of a it was like a sports
commentator
or like a couple of them talking to each
other and it was constant chatter
about how well i was mowing the grass
so if you listened in on my thoughts at
any point
for the hours and hours that i was
mowing all those lawns
like i wasn't daydreaming at least half
the time
it wasn't daydreaming or like you know
just zoning out
it was listening to these commentators
that i was manufacturing talking about
oh
yeah that corner you know he kind of
missed a little grass he's going to have
to go back for that one on the second
round
and then oh the grass is a little long
this day what's his strategy going to be
and then ultimately how long did it take
him to cut miss bethune's grass
and get paid while listening to her talk
about her ceramics
be nice but not stay too long that he's
gonna get home before dark
you know it was and i just thought it
was
it was motivating for me like i listened
to these voices and i got
really good at mowing grass
but it wasn't this it wasn't an outlet
it was just
it was a barrage of assessment well it
was constantly there it's striking
how similar the inner
thoughts inner dialogue of a three is to
a one to hear you say that
so for me it's here's a standard of
perfection
are you are you a cheat are you i'll say
i'll use the word achieve are you
achieving it or not
but i guess your inner critic is is
saying achieve something different
no no so well it's so similar and that's
why and
first of all people and i there are
people that i'm close to
that that are not into the enneagram and
i don't know if they're a three or a one
which
you may be like what it seems so
different okay here's why it's not
different
because the net effect of you having
this
inner critic that won't show shut up
that's in the form of these two
you know announcers is that you're
constantly focusing on your performance
you you may be doing it because you
don't want to make a mistake now
shift the the analogy a little bit
and just say i'm mowing the grass well
what am i thinking about i'm not
thinking about the two
commentators i'm talking i'm thinking
about the crowd that is
watching i'm thinking about the audience
so i don't have an
internal critic i have an inner audience
that i am performing for constantly i
told my therapist about this
and a lot of times frankly
it's my parents and my brother it's my
family it's my immediate family
like i'll be doing something so as a 43
year old man
i'll be doing something stupid like
cleaning a window or painting something
or
changing a tire on my kid's bicycle
and i picture them watching me and
saying
he's doing a pretty good job with that
bicycle tire
i mean now of course it manifests itself
in things like oh well he's on the
tonight show
or he just want to he just wanted an
award for that show that he makes on the
internet
but it is these inner
audience that i'm performing for when
you talk about that in sec
it's all they're always there the cloud
of witnesses
they're always there they're always
watching and i hope they're always
impressed
right and and i if i'm by myself
if i'm i mean one of the things i
struggle with when i meditate
is the moment that i begin to
focus on my breath in a way that's
actually not encumbered by my thoughts
which is very difficult for me to do
the moment that i focus on my breath the
audience is like he's doing it he's
focusing on his breath
it's like and it goes right back to
having to perform and it's the most
difficult thing
to shed and to let go but again if
you're just watching somebody on the
outside you just see two guys doing a
really damn good job cutting grass
one guy link the one is is competing
against this inner standard that he's
established for himself
and the other guy who's doing a really
good job as well
is thinking about the guy across the
street with a mower and how he's better
than him
how he's doing a better job than all the
other people who might be mowing
and he's obsessed with not just beating
his own standard
but beating the standard what's the
standard for mowing in lillington
whatever that is i'm going to the top
yeah and it's
in it again a lot of these inner
struggles like when you think when you
talk about any
the you you might feel exhausted when
you hear about the inner dialogue of a
one and a three i think that's probably
the case for
most any uh the way that i talk to jesse
i mean
the inner dialogue of it too it's like
oh that is i feel so sorry for you
that is exhausting because this is the
thing that you're constantly
running from i can't take a vacation
right i'm a workaholic right
so i go on vacation like here's a
perfect example
a couple years ago we were getting ready
for our
tour uh the rhett link sing
song tour whatever we call it you know
that was not what we called it yeah
and uh i had i told everybody that i was
going to learn how to play the piano
and for this tour right so of course now
that i did that i had to do it
and i'm sitting on vacation
in cabo san lucas next to a pool
relaxing now my wife is doing she can
relax she can do it
day one of a vacation she's poolside
she's got a book that's like fiction
like a fiction book you know
and she's just enjoying herself one of
the reasons i have trouble reading
fiction is i feel like i'm not fixing
anything i'm not learning anything
it's just a story that's going to go in
one ear and out the other
but i remember sitting poolside and i
was like
boy you know what this is the perfect
opportunity for
this is a perfect opportunity to write a
song because we got i gotta write a song
for this
i gotta play the piano i gotta write a
song
and i wrote that's why i travel and
that's why it's about being at a mexican
resort because i was
at a mexican resort at the time and it
was like and i
and again you have to be doing something
and if i don't
be achieving something if i choose to be
like you know what today i'm not writing
a song i'm not thinking about i'm not
contemplating a project i'm not trying
to be a better me
i'm just being again that's the ultimate
thing for three is
stop doing and start being learn how to
be
not do very difficult for me to to do
because the moment that i do don't do
anything
i get this this it feels like the world
is caving in
even this past weekend i spent like an
afternoon
um i watched a movie and then i kind of
just
napped on saturday yeah and it was like
a four-hour window where it was like
there was a movie and then a nap
and at the end of that i was like i feel
horrible
like what could i what else could i have
done in that four hours i could have
like
i could have figured something out
creatively well this is what i did this
weekend
uh were you done with your thought
though yeah well i want to come back to
the sp to the wings in a second because
the wing
but i want to hear what you got to say
yeah for me this
this weekend it was um
you know like i i was vacuuming
the vents yeah the vents yeah they get
dirty because you look up there and you
can start to see the boiler they're
dirty and i would take them down and i
realized there was so much more i could
do to vacuum inside of the vent
yeah when i was done with all that i
realized that the vacuum cleaner
was really dirty so i had i disassembled
the vacuum cleaner
and cleaned all of it and
the thing about once is uh we can relax
if we can manage to put things in just
the right order
um we can have this sense of well-being
when things are
are put in their place yeah like oh i've
cleaned and the thing that i cleaned
with
is now totally clean so now i can relax
but if i just clean the vents
and i made my vacuum cleaner dirty well
i've created a problem and that's not
that's not made right yet so i couldn't
i couldn't chill out now this is a
this is a trap of course but i do know
that sometimes when i'm when i'm
cleaning or organizing those things make
me feel better because they give me
that sense of control which is
associated
with uh achieving perfection in my own
mind
con control is re is really for me
like nailing perfection yeah yeah so
it's
it's it's it's not about whether it's
it's out of my control or in my control
it's like it's whether
the res i can achieve a result with
control
and there's you know there's plenty of
things that i will not
i get very sensitive to to signing up
for things
if i don't know what
if i don't know how to get to the to the
end goal of
perfection like if it's if it's
open-ended or if i feel like it's a big
commitment and i'm i'm not going to be
able to
if i get 80 or 70 percent even if it's a
friendship remember that story i told
about the guy
who was just like he was just an a
friend who wanted to continue to be a
friend and i broke up with him because i
didn't feel like i could be good
a good enough friend to him so i like
preemptively just
broke up with the guy i mean that's
that's what was behind it well and
and this is another area where the
threes and the ones are so alike in fact
the three one combo which we'll talk
more about next week
there's actually a nickname for the
three one combo oh don't don't tell them
i don't know what it is
it's okay but basically it's the
it's the combo of numbers that will
accomplish the most if you put them
together
oh because they're both
ultimately super committed to
results and again like okay so the one
like
what you're saying is you're hesitant to
enter into a situation
if you don't feel like you're gonna be
able to do it and you're gonna be able
to control it
a three will gladly very they will sign
up we will get right in
we have no idea we haven't been educated
in this area we've never done it before
it doesn't matter
we're jumping in the moment that we
begin to
believe that we will not achieve that's
when we bail
most three and for me i i cannot bail
so it's like if i sign up for it i feel
like i have to do it
so it's like so i think that again this
the 3-1
combo is that i will convince
you to jump into something
and then i've got this pathological
confidence that we will be able to
figure it out and do it
and then once you set your mind to it
now we're a team you know and so it it
ends up
like again we kind of talked before we
understood the enneagram we talked about
it with like
the analogy of like you got one guy who
gets the ball
rolling and you got the other guy who
keeps the ball rolling a starter and a
finisher
and that is how it manifests itself a
lot as reason was
now interestingly as this relates to i
want to talk about the wings a little
bit so
an aspect of the enneagram is that
you can be a number with a wing
and the wing isn't the number that is
immediately adjacent to each side of you
so
i could be a three with a two wing or a
three with a four wing and you can also
be a three without a wing right
but as the more i read about three i'm
definitely not a two first one let me
just say right now
two which is what my wife is which is a
helper
and again i think that's kind of a
demeaning name to give to the two
there are better names for it in other
books it makes it seem like i'm just
here to help
it just basically means that they kind
of give themselves to people in ways
that are just monumental
i'm not that in fact i score the lowest
on two like if you look at my scores
like two is like barely ticking
but four which is the individualist i
actually scored pretty high on
and the three with a four wing this is
let me
i'm going to read this is from millennia
graham so
a three with a four wing means that i'm
most concerned with what i produce
and put out into the world so that's
where i found my value
it's not just necessarily like hey now
again it is like hey we're doing this
thing where we're throwing darts at a
boardwalk i'm going to do the damnedest
job i can possibly do in this game
that's why i'm so competitive in gmm in
a lot of ways right because
you just put a challenge in front of me
and i'm just like well how do you win
this
but really it manifests itself
in i am trying
to find my worth in the things that i
produce right and so what that ends up
doing is the net effect of that is
every single thing that we produce
every single thing that we put out into
the world my self-worth
is attached to it now that's kind of
true you might say that's true for all
creative people
i believe that it is true in a lot of
ways but it is
like fundamental to my core that i have
been in this long
adulthood battle to detach my self-worth
from the success of what we do but
that's my tendency my tendency and i
think that's one of the reasons that
when i'm not healthy
i get so defensive so we talked um
you know last week or a couple weeks ago
about you know
failed projects gmm-22 the multi-episode
version of gmm
when it failed and we in when it was in
the midst of failing when it was in the
midst of getting this
incredibly negative reaction from fans
we decided that we were going to do a
podcast and talk about it now
we made the mistake of just being like
we're just going to be real and raw
and just process this live
i made an ass in myself in a lot of ways
right i was super defensive
i insulted people who had were
disappointed in us
i was like a cornered uh dog
you know and i attacked and i lashed out
what i have come to understand is that
i was defending my own worth
not saying it was healthy it was
unhealthy because i had so attached
i had identified my self-worth with the
success of the show
when people were rejecting the show they
weren't just rejecting
me they were telling me that kind of
worthless like you took this time
you hired all these people you put all
this thought and effort into this
thing you know what it's [ __ ] man that's
what it is
it's the shittiest thing you guys have
ever done and so what i hear is
you're [ __ ] you're worthless
yeah i i may have told you that too so
and so when i'm in when i'm in the bad
heads but you know actually
well first of all i should have never
made that podcast i don't think
maybe maybe we learned something from it
but if i had to go back
i think there was a way to process that
rejection
in a healthy way but that wasn't what i
did
because i ty as a three with a four wing
it's about the things that i bring to
you i'm like here's something else
here's something else here's a book
here's a concert here's a
here's a song here here you know i'm
saying i'm constantly bringing you
things
and you're i'm like am i aborted
something now is it okay am i enough now
can i stop that's the process that's
going on
and you know they talk about the
emotional passion associated with each
one
is what is that for a three the
emotional
passion yeah for
uh a one it is anger oh yeah for uh
three is a deceit
okay so does that i don't know how that
plays into this because
to me it feels like the thing that i
access is that
okay um ones most often feel resentment
which is a kind of a low level
background tamp
down anger that things aren't as they
should be
so i try to remember i don't remember
what i said in that podcast and how i
was processing that
but i i think that something that had to
be going on
was just this frustration that it didn't
work
and that i i mean my mind definitely
goes back to the things that we
foresaw that we needed to work in terms
of the tool like i start to blame
how youtube worked and we talked a lot
about that because and i fixated on that
because
i felt like we had a plan and there's
things that we needed
that did that didn't exist it didn't
work
in a way to give the audience the
experience that
i wanted the perfect the perfect
experience
wasn't possible and when it became
impossible
and it it didn't it didn't pan out and
didn't meet my standard
i just got very resentful
and frustrated because there was there
was no way forward
it failed because it just
it it wasn't gonna come together you
know uh
so for me that's that's where the anger
comes
that's that's how i experience this
anger this like
seething frustration that things aren't
right and i do think that's like well i
knew i knew
what it would take and but that part was
out of our control and when we asked for
it we didn't get it and now i'm just
mad because it feels like uh
it feels like i'm wrong and i'm bad but
it wasn't me it wasn't my
fault and and this on a on a like a
smaller level than the gmm 22 thing
um and we talk about this openly
you know we'll be in the middle of
say a production of some kind that's
getting that's getting
i i begin to feel this is a little much
like this is taking a lot of time
there's a whole lot going on here and
then like will be it'll be like
wednesday in the middle of a week and
i'll be like link seems angry today
right and i think it's because
there's so many things going on and may
or you tell me maybe it's like
i feel like i i'm losing my sense of
understanding
and control i feel like i'm on a roller
coaster that is suddenly like one of the
wheels may have just come off
i always have an idea of how things
should be going
and when it's not it's happening
then it it just yeah it's very
frustrating
it's very frustrating but you don't
because i've seen it but i've seen it
happen
it's not a passive like there might be
some types like i think a nine
uh tends to sort of retreat a little bit
one doesn't retreat one turns up the
volume i can fix this for the
aggressiveness
i can it's not too late to fix this and
we talk about that sometimes i'm like
you're being a little
you're being a little aggressive being a
little aggressive right now because
you're like if i well if i could turn up
the volume on this
and we could just get through this if i
can dig if i can dig my claws into it
deeper
and start to steer it or mold it yeah
then
maybe it's not too late now the whole
deceit i'm glad you asked that question
so
you might be like what do you mean what
does that mean that the threes sort of
passion
is deceit wouldn't it be pride no
actually the two's
passion is pride talk to my wife about
that
um again just to just to remind you
we don't actually think that we're great
we just want to
seem like we're great right again i i
use this is a this is a
funny analogy but i just i use the
example
of of i'm not trying to make you feel
sorry for me i grow a beard because i do
not like the way my face looks without
it
right i am actively deceiving you
except for those of you who are able to
find that picture that's all over the
damn place
it's easy to find and it's the worst i
don't actually look
that bad without a beard that picture
that you took
something about my hair my expression i
was a
i was a little bit overweight in the
chin area it's the worst picture
on the internet and it's like a meme now
can you tell that i'm upset about it
because i can't control my image like a
three plus two
um but again what i want to do is i want
to
deceive you so i don't want to you're
talking like
snapchat filters but in across your
whole life
well i again i i want to be very clear
and i don't want to
mischaracterize threes or my or
mischaracterize myself because again i'm
i'm not a liar
i don't like get into a situation i
don't cheat on my taxes i don't have an
offshore account
you know i'm not that kind of person i'm
sure there are many threes who are
but that that active sort of deception
is not what it is it's a very it's
much more subtle and it's much more
sneaky because i
am lying to myself
i'm trying to present myself to myself
in a way that is acceptable
so we might be we might be in gmo 22.
gmm 22's falling apart
and i'm trying to find a way to
reposition
the argument so that i'm still okay and
so then i say
things like you guys don't even
understand how you're supposed to
understand this thing
you know i don't remember what kind of
stuff i said but again i don't actually
believe that
i know if my inner self knows
this is failing it isn't good but i
can't
deal with it not being good so i'm going
to start lying to myself and i'm going
to start
lying to you not ju some big giant lie
but i'm going to start
spin spinning it a little bit that's why
we make great politicians because you
can
ask us about well why do you did you say
this in 1998 now you're saying
this now it's like well let me tell you
why you're wrong i'm right it was never
a change it was the same thing it was
just a slightly different emphasis we're
masters
at that kind of deception but again
we're lying
to ourselves as much as we're lying to
you i mean i can definitely see
that even for me i might try to change
the rules in order to then
like my measurement of perfection look
at it in a different way
i i think one one of the challenges for
me is just
judging you know i'm constantly judging
myself
um but then i'm i'm judging everything
or assessing everything to then know
what that standard is
like i'm always searching for the
standard matter of fact
like when i was choosing which type of
engineering i wanted to go into
uh i gravitated towards industrial
engineering
one of the reasons was because it was
all about taking something that
it you know you weren't it wasn't about
making something
it was about how you make it how you go
about it the way you do it there is
it was such a focus on procedure and
systems that it really resonated with me
i was like okay just like any math
problem
there's a there's steps to then get to a
solution
there is there's a best way to do
something
and there's always a way to improve
something to get closer and closer to
perfection
you know i i think that i know that
perfection is an illusion
but it's i have this drive
to get as close as i can to start you
know
to dial the fine-tuning as much as
possible so like
very detail-oriented it's like
any little thing to get
everything in order so that's why i even
went into
uh engineering industrial engineering
specifically
was was for that reason and it's
again my three-ness it gives a
very clear explanation as to
how i navigated my engineering situation
right so
okay so i went into engineering because
originally i wanted to be an architect
like growing up i wanted to be an
architect and i would like do house
plans and stuff like that
and then i someone told me that design
school
was like really really difficult and it
was a lot of time
and so i was like that doesn't sound fun
that sounds too
hard maybe but you know what structural
engineering is like the engineering side
of design school so i can still kind of
be involved in architecture
and you know my friends like link are
going into engineering i've been told
that i'm good at math
okay i'll i'll do that and so then
halfway through
my freshman year i'm or maybe it was
myself i can't remember
i'm taking a structural engineering
class i'm like this is the hardest thing
i've ever taken in my life like
i i don't know if i understand what's
going on
like i admit i'm like i've been able to
sort of fake it and make a's there's no
real
weird place to hide but like this i
think this guy's gonna give me a c
i've never gotten a c in my life
and at that moment when i started to see
that i don't know if i didn't know if i
could succeed i was like well
oh there's also this concentration in
civil engineering called hydrology
which is just like dealing with water
how how hard is that
okay right and so i switched over to
like straight-up civil engineering with
a
with a concentration in hydrology and it
was
easier and i had more fun right but
again
it was the three in me it was the three
facing an obstacle that he thought he
couldn't actually again
i got myself into it i went into
engineering
but once i was like oh you actually
can't succeed in this in this lane
i shifted i think another thing for me
is like now
everything we do has a post-mortem well
this has always been the case creatively
whenever we make anything and i'm
talking about like at every stage of the
process so
if we we shoot an episode a good
mythical morning
well we we go back
to the dressing room and we're like you
know
get getting on with our day i wa i am
talk i am
thinking and talking about everything
that just happened
to assess what could have been better
because
it's never come back and like well that
was good man
like i very rarely shoot an episode like
that was good
it's always like you know what i can
always find something
and i hate these meetings by the way
yeah and we institutionalize this thing
where
if you know there's always a lesson to
be learned
in order to make something incrementally
better and the increments get smaller
and smaller and smaller but my tenacity
to find it it gets more intense and more
intense i'm like i have we have to have
something
because it i know it's not perfect
because i know that's an illusion but we
can always get closer and what i
always tell you in those in those
meetings and again i think that i'm glad
we do the meetings i'm not saying we
shouldn't do the meetings
but a lot of times you'll see me frame
things like you know
you may be right that we can learn this
little lesson
and we can make this improvement in the
grand scheme of things
do you think it will make a substance
substantially better product right
now maybe it will but i always kind of
try to talk myself into like yeah but
what
what else could we be doing with our
time like let's find what else could we
achieve
let's find something else to achieve i i
i there's this
this idea that i got from millennia
graham where it talks about
threes actually are addicted to
achieving
and competing with ourselves always
aiming for another level of success that
is just out of reach it's
tantalizingly out of reach so you know
we talk about all the other stuff that
we try to do
and we're like try you know we're trying
to do something in a traditional space
we're trying to get a tv show on the air
we're trying to
to make a movie we're trying to do these
things
it feels like it's this next level of
success now i understand that like
there's more kids in fact mr beast did a
survey on twitter
that showed that more people want to be
youtubers than actors or more people
want to be successful on youtube than in
the traditional space
i get that i understand that but i ain't
a kid and
i've been successful in the youtube
space yeah you've done it
i've done it and so it's like all right
what else can i do right and so
and i actually i gravitate towards
things that
feel like it probably won't be able to
happen they feel like they're out of
reach because i'm
addicted to reaching for something
that's just out of reach
and then possibly getting it um i want
to talk about
and it drives me crazy because i'm like
oh he's gonna what's the next thing he's
gonna sign me up for
that i have to perfect right and you
know
i feel like i have a limited capacity to
to continue to drill into things right
because everything that we've added
is is still in my mind on my plate has
to be perfected you know it's
i've you know i've actually put shed
some things from my plate and shed
some of some of this desire to you know
to
to round the edges and perfect every
little thing but it is a tendency
and at those moments where it's like
we're jumping into this next thing
let's make it happen i'm like
what is he signing me up for right you
know
even when you go back to all the layers
like this is a conversation we had in an
early podcast where you're like it's
that next thing that you want to
experience um and you did talk about it
in terms of experience but
i have to think there's like an
achievement
i can now pilot an ultralight i can now
do this i i'm guessing but for me it's
like
okay am i going to get into this genre
of music because then i need to know
i need to collect everything in that
genre or it's not always
like if you use if you use surfing as an
example like
you know i also tend to sign up for
things that okay i'm six foot seven and
i'm
in my mid 40s like being i'm never going
to be a good surfer i'm never going to
be the kind of person that like i'm not
trying to be i was never trying to be
like
a real surfer a professional surfer for
god's sake
but like just the idea of like being
someone who doesn't look awkward and
embarrassing if you happen to
what be watching them and a lot but a
lot of people are watching me because
i'm so damn big
that's why you don't want to do stand-up
paddleboard um
well there's a reason there's multiple
reasons why i don't want to do stand-up
paddleboard
yeah i don't like drawing attention to
myself doing something poorly and being
on a stand up paddle board you're
already sort of an outcast there's also
beaches that you can't go to whatever
but yeah i struggle with it
but in health i am able to be like
i can just experience this i can just
experience
the ocean i can just experience in these
projects that we're doing that may never
come to the light of day
may never see the light of day the
process
being not being i am doing and i'm not
going to stop doing it's not the answer
is not to stop doing but the
the answer is to be able to be in the
midst of doing right
but i want to talk a little bit about
feelings yeah let's talk about that and
i do think that
because what we were about to get into
would be good thing to
to to talk about next episode is
what we're doing with all of this
information
in terms of growth and integration as
well as
our interactions yes yeah yeah yeah so
i'm just going to set up one
additional i just controlled the i just
can't i just produce the other i'm just
let me just do it i
i just want to set up like one yeah and
we can talk how and how i'm dealing with
this
next time and also talk about like the
three in one relationship
the two three relationship and my
marriage the 1-6 relationship in your
marriage maybe even some parenting
things
this has impacted our parenting but
this is going to surprise you if you
don't know anything about the enneagram
but there are different triads right
there's nine
total numbers and so there's three three
and three and there's a triad
called the feeling triad these p
this is called the heart center these
are the people who are
most in their heart and have the most
feelings
and three is right in the middle of the
feeling triad you're like what
what that doesn't make any sense you
don't seem like you are you don't feel
that much you don't seem very sensitive
well threes are not known as feeling
people
rather they are people of action and
achievement we've actually
put our feelings in a box so that we can
get ahead with whatever we want to
achieve
we believe that emotions get in the way
of our performance so we substitute
thinking and practical action for
feelings
but let me tell you we have a lot
of feelings and this is why i am in
therapy
okay because
i am naturally very
sensitive and feeling things
deeply all the time but those
feelings seem so impractical
they seem they're not pragmatic at all
how is a feeling
going to help me do something and so we
become
masters at putting a dam up
between us and our feelings and let me
tell you
that dam cracks and that dam
can burst and it can make things happen
weird in your body and
you can give you lower back pain and it
can give you almost a detached retina or
whatever it was that happened to me i
know it wasn't that it was something
else
it can manifest itself in health
problems which i've had a lot of them
uh skin conditions and because you can
become an
expert at being like i
can have this really strong feeling and
i can i'm an expert at
transmuting a feeling
into an action like it just bypasses
right past me it's like
having this strong feeling boom what's
the plan like if i have a conversation
with my wife and she's dealing with
something where what she needs is
comfort what she needs is a listening
ear what she needs is someone to
actually
get into the trench with her i want to
show you the way out
i want to immediately give you a
solution and let's begin to do it right
now let's not sit in this discomfort
so we're not good at comforting people
i'm not good at going and seeing
somebody
in a hospital bed i'm not good at
knowing what to say at a funeral i'm the
worst
in threes might be the worst because
we stay so far away from feelings
but inside there's this giant
water wheel turning with all with the
power of all these feelings
and it makes us need therapy
if you're a three if everybody needs
therapy
but if you're a three and you want to be
healthy you especially need it
because well you're saying that because
you're a three yeah yeah but
everybody everybody everybody needs
therapy is my is my opinion
but because the threes my opinion is i
know i need it and i'm gonna stay out of
their business
no what i'm saying is that a three is
feeling the most
and suppressing the most and i never
understood that like
jessie would tell me all the time she
was like i would be like i just i'm just
not that sensitive i'm really
independent
i'm not that sensitive i don't care what
people say to me i don't care
like you don't have to give me birthday
gifts i don't i'm never an inconvenience
for people
i'm super stable and reliable like i
pride myself on all these things
i don't really have that many feelings
but i was having
giant waves of feelings that i was able
to divert
it was this is a revelation to yourself
and in therapy
i have been able to i mean i'm in like
my third year of therapy
peel back those layers and be like oh no
there is a feeling and that feeling does
not need to be
transformed into action that feeling
needs to be
felt and we'll keep going
with that next week i think you know as
a one i think i'm in the gut triad
honestly i don't know what that means um
i also find it interesting that like in
this
in in this episode as we wrap
up it
it felt like you had you took the
opportunity to like
um help people understand some
misconceptions about
you you know it's like because because
i'm into image management and i think
i don't i don't know what my drive is i
don't know i'll think about that
but uh for next week
i think yeah because there's there's
still lots of there's lots of good stuff
in terms of like okay where do we go
from here that like
it'll be fun to process in the next one
so uh
i say let's leave it at that but you
need to give a wreck
yeah so there's a bunch of good books uh
that we have read
and and really i i i would be lying to
you if i told you that i had read all
through
all of these good thing is that you only
have to read like the parts about
your number at first so it's like a big
book you can have a sense of
achievement or that you didn't you
didn't quit
so i i'll say that if you want to go if
you want to go a little bit deeper
uh the complete enneagram or the wisdom
of the enneagram
are great but if you are like most
people these days and you don't want to
go deeper
because it takes a lot of time and you
want to read something that
is a little bit more approachable a
little bit more irreverent i think the
millennia agrees
i'd say it's a lot more irreverent you
gotta like f bombs
but it's a it's a really fun book uh
millennia graham by hannah pasch
this is definitely um
i mean first of all it's great and like
a lot of the stuff that i talked about
today
came directly from the insights in this
book
uh but it it doesn't go as deep into
like
the background of how this whole thing
came about and it doesn't feel as
technical and i'm saying that
for most people that's a good thing it's
approachable it's digestible
millennia graham uh it's pretty too look
at that
it's got a bunch of colors on the front
yeah i like it
lots of fun all right we'll keep this
going next week but hey go ahead
hashtag your biscuits let us know about
your experience
what if you're a one or three what
what's resonating or
um just as you've been exposed to this
what's your experience
with the enneagram and maybe over the
next week
now that you've heard this episode you
can actually begin to explore this for
yourself maybe
when you when you listen to next week's
episode you'll already know or begin to
be
knowing what you are to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]